Ma guarda che mi viene a vedere chi sono
[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti al nuovo
episodio di sounds of the forest
iniziare a fare SMR Secondo me cioè è
un'evoluzione E comunque vabbè Eravamo
rimasti ragazzi che il nostro esperto
videogiocatore qua l'altra volta ha
fatto la giocata e ovviamente sto
parlando di Kelvin che costruisce da
solo Sta Villa gigantesca e se l'ago
Guarda questo la gode Allora fratello
ehm dedicati alla struttura quella
dietro tanto eh Vedo che te la cavi col
fai da te devo fare così ok posso
cucinare anche una buonissima Arrow
gamba che con un pizzico di basilico è
bijoux ed ecco il nostro buonissimo Row
carne arrostita Sarei curioso di vedere
come si mangiano le braccia stigo No
perché veramente Ah è buono e Twix
mangia
a posto era buonissimo devo aprire un
ristorante Gourmet a Milano io che ne so
di ste cose ma non ho capito che cazzo
devo fare qua Ah di sopra Che stupido
Quindi tu non puoi metterli a caso i
pezzi devi proprio mettere quelli giusti
Kelvin Tu sei un pazzo scalmanato
sclerotico e quindi ragazzi Anche questa
è fatta teoricamente dovrebbe essere
finita 1 2 Vai Kelvin È tutto tuo si è
chiusa la porta
Kelvin e falla l'entrata Non è che
possiamo hai capito Cioè si può si può
entrare come cazzo ci entro in questa
casa qua a parte Ah ah
ah è scorrevole cioè certo non avevo
dubbi Vabbè Ragazzi allora il momento di
andare in exporation perché abbiamo
fatto un bellissimo accampamento Secondo
me adesso esce la casetta andiamo
finalmente in esplorazione Io direi di
andare dove ci sono gli ertag ragazzi
Quindi nei punti viola molto importante
questo perché effettivamente se ci
pensiamo nei punti Viola ci sono proprio
gli ertag quindi vuol dire che c'è
qualcosa di tecnologico in quella in
quel punto Là ci stiamo avvicinando
all'altro ertac ma tra l'altro quanto è
fatta bene sta roba Raga ma scusate ma
che figo è bellissimo Scusa veramente è
veramente bello raga l'altro Air tag più
o meno dovrebbe essere qua il
geolocalizzatore non so bene eh Che cosa
possiamo trovare io vado con la pistola
per essere sicuri tanto non ho neanche
troppa vita quindi magari se riuscissi a
trovare delle medicine in giro Non
sarebbe nemmeno troppo male insomma
ragazzi lo sento
sta lampeggiando attenzione Ma minchia
ma non è che è una bomba
è questo Ho trovato una corda
della roba da mangiare del vino
Che cazzo è Dov'è l'artag Porca vacca
Sono vivo sono ancora vivo e dove
minchia Eh
oh santo Iddio Ok Credo di aver trovato
lertag ragazzi credo Si può tagliare
Madonna Raga ma che ansia sta roba
mi sono trovato un walkie talkie Ecco
questo è il GPS la torcia Minchia grazie
a Dio grazie brutto stronzo chi sei Ho
una ragazzi e culo puoi guardare la
torcia serve eh la torcia serve
veramente un sacco potremmo tornare
nelle caverne e fare una runne fatta
bene dirigiamoci ragazzi al prossimo
punto Viola vedo tra l'altro che nel
tragitto per arrivare là c'è un altro
Punto Verde Se vi ricordate il primo
punto verde quello in basso ci ho
trovato un Caddy abbandonato a se stesso
Non serviva a niente magari in questo
c'è qualcosa di utile tanto ci dobbiamo
passare per arrivare al punto Viola
quindi passiamoci Vediamo che succede
Allora ragazzi siamo vicinissimi al
Punto Verde che è qua Eccolo un altro Ka
Oh Salve mi può portare fino alla sfera
Perché mi fai perché mi fa vedere i
Caddy no c'è una caverna qua Minchia
cioè i punti verdi sono Katy però qua
effettivamente ci sono delle caverne
quindi questo questo che di ha un
qualcosa vicino allora entro un attimo
allora non voglio fare la caverna perché
sennò
diventa un disastro però almeno per
vedere se trovo medicinali nell'entrata
che serve appunto c'ho la torcia secondo
me un attimo la torcia Please Madonna
ragazzi l'utilità di sta torcia È
incredibile in teoria all'entrata vicino
Ci dovrebbero essere le risorse cose in
genere ci sono sempre
altra tuo padre
fudentalining
Che cazzo è raga Una botola Minchia
siamo il lost oh oh oh
What the fuck
No ragazzi che cazzo è incredibile
c'è tutto fuden diving c'è veramente ci
sono risorse Raga ho trovato un bunker
delle Ma cosa è successo qua Dardo per
Balestra rispetto a quello che ho
mangiato fuori io ostriche Io in realtà
dovrei essere Timmy il bambino del primo
the forest teoricamente ragazzi non lo
so Quindi teoricamente Questo è un
sequel non un pericolo sbagliato Non lo
so ragazzi però sembrerebbe un sequel
dal dalla tecnologia che vedo perché è
molto più avanzata di the forest normale
quindi devo recuperare ehm questo
miliardario scomparso non so che cosa
stiano facendo qua questa parte è chiusa
Mi serve una tessera Va bene vai fin qua
vediamo C'è molto sangue non mi fido
moltissimo e io stare qua gocce del gas
magari non spariamo con la pistola Ma
cosa
va bene Sì qua Sento rumori strani tipo
un elicottero Comunque serve una tessera
una tessera che non ho nel frattempo ho
trovato un sacco di viveri ma non male
No ma avrei preferito medicine ma
abbiamo ancora il punto viola da
scoprire bello c'è un bunker nascosto
quindi molto ci sono molti più segreti
qua che nell'altro the forest A quanto
pare c'è molta più roba tecnologica
Bellissima sta cosa
okelvin Minchia non è non hai idea di
cosa ho trovato ho trovato il McDonald's
qua sotto c'è il McDonald Vuoi mangiare
Eccolo E allora gliene frega niente
potrei essere andato anche al centro
commerciale che gliene porta a lui
l'altro punto verde dove c'è il Kelly
allora A quel punto forse nascondeva un
altro bunker che non ho visto perché a
quanto pare i punti verdi non sono
ok Dicevo a quanto pare i punti verdi
non sono i Caddy ma sono i bunkers
medicine medicine fratello ti prego no
Perché trovo tutto meno che quello che
mi serve nella vita sempre o nei giochi
sai la medicina per caso no però posso
dormire devo aver dormito lui che non
promette benissimo Però lui è finito
male ok corde per teleferica che ancora
non ho capito bene come funzioni state
deferica Però vabbè Quello è un
dettaglio qua posso bere mi deve
lampeggiarmi per forza perché l'ansia me
la deve mettere a quanto pare però vabbè
Eccolo
c'è una croce
Ah quindi è sotto terra è sepolto e come
cazzo che c'è una pala Kelvin ragazze
Quando servi Eccoti Che stai facendo
Stai cagando riesci tipo a scavare
qualcosa del genere questo devi
recupera' resta sgombra Seguimi Recupera
raga me la devo cavare da solo ma non ho
la minima idea di come di come si chiama
che non ho la para io posso provare a
fare una cosa ma non so quanto serva
Vabbè tanto abbiamo salvato Volendo
possiamo provare a farlo Ho una bomba
temporizzata posso provare a buttarla
per terra e vedere che succede però è un
po' Too Much sostanzialmente Vabbè dai
proviamoci
Minchia via
non ha funzionato eh
buongiorno Salve no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no niente Guarda giuro
non ho niente Ho una croce è una croce
Viva Gesù Cristo Mi scusi
è questa
Ciao No no no no nulla nulla nulla
è una croce di Gesù Cristo Oh
Ma che cazzo è questa fratella non ti
faccio niente
no telecamera No no no Hai rotto il
cazzo
Cosa cosa
Raga ma chi è
Ma chi è
Mi scusi dove va Vedi qua quanto cazzo
occorre abbia quattro gambe la faccio
dopo Cazzo Oh
vieni qua non so chi t'è muort io Dai
che buio non l'ho persa raga Porca
[__] lo sapevo dov'è no raga l'ho
persa Eh non vedo niente una c'ha
veramente uh
dove cazzo è andata Non vedo nulla si è
fatto pure buio io caga Croce
Viva Gesù Cristo ok Questo è il bunker
di è vicino al si avvicina al bunker di
prima
sono in una giornata Eh ragazzi è
diventato Slender Man cioè totalmente al
buio Pessima scelta ragazzi Pessima
scelta Oh siamo tornati raga Meno male
caso non c'è casa Fatemi dormire un
attimo perché non vedo una sega da ieri
Ok perfetto Oh merenda un bel braccio Oh
Ma chi sei
stai fermo
Beh è il mio saluto questo il tuo era
molto più Pacifico per altri saluti
Vienimi a trovare il martedì e il
giovedì è che sono qua per te Francesca
a mangiare si può mangiare
mais è la colazione se è fatta Lo prendo
Ok Daje fuoco allo zio che almeno
recuperiamo i pezzi detto questo Ragazzi
l'unica Verna me ne sono fatta una sola
quindi io teoricamente Dovrei entrare
nelle altre perché se non entro nelle
caverne non finiamo il gioco perché là è
c'è tutto praticamente le caverne ci
dovrebbe essere tutto quello che ci
serve per proseguire
Eccolo ma allora sono orbo c'era il
Caddy che era questo e c'è anche il
bunker raga Sono stupido Minchia subito
a vedere cosa c'è dentro No mi serve
perché qua o da una parte o dall'altra
ci deve essere la tessera Secondo me
ragazzi la tessera si trova dove c'è
sepolto quel tizio con l'artag Sono
quasi sicuro di questo perché non la
metterebbero mai nell'altro bunker
Quindi io credo che qua ci sia un altro
bunker Esatto Vedi che c'ho ragione però
qua ci vedo la pistola e col cazzo che
c'entro senza Buongiorno
Ah no è un poster
Minchia ma è grossissimo questo qua
c'è una stampante 3D sto male cos'è
resina ah ho messo una resina per la 3D
printer la posso usarla sta stampando No
Ah eccola Ah puoi stampare ma sto male
puoi stampare le frecce sto male è
bellissimo È geniale che è
Vabbè allegro tanto posso stampare un
miliardo di freccia perché veramente
ad resina su printer
frecce stampate in 3D Ragazzi ma io non
ne posso stampare un miliardo minchia
devo veramente prendere di Tutto qua
Grazie
giacchetta sta minchia questo è
utilissima vediamo se c'è qualcos'altro
maschera
Rampini tessuto tecnico
la slitta puoi stampare una cazzo di
slitta maschera Ma io saprei una
maschera un tessuto tecnico ma non ho
capito la maschera forse mi serve per
non farmi attaccare dagli indigeni Eh
ragazzi potrebbe essere cioè Ragazzi sto
male sto male Va bene
batterie ok Infatti non dovrei tenere la
torcia troppo accesa Ragazzi qua perché
sennò la sprechiamo Allora prendiamo la
maschera perfetto la posso indossare qua
qua maschera rossa equipaggia hanno la
puoi tenere sopra la puoi fare solo così
ok Probabilmente se becco qualche
indigeno me la metto su e teoricamente
dovrebbe servire teoricamente ragazzi
non lo so Ricordiamoci raga che mi serve
una tessera per entrare nell'altro
bunker
ok
ok È una parte del bunker Ma chi è che
ha costruito sta roba Ragazzi comunque
cioè veramente incredibile eh C'è una
soldi orologi
e anche qua c'è una musichetta la sento
c'è una radio là dietro però anche qua
non posso entrare Ci volevate essere
[__] tessera so dove la trovo la
tessera e sepolta col tizio nel punto
Viola mimici gioco quello che volete
ragazzi che l'amici gioco quello che
volete e per disseppellire il tizio
sepolto là sopra sicuramente devo
trovare una pala che si troverà nelle
caverne 100% ma lo so io Ma non è
scritta sta roba manca a farsi un bel
giro per le caverne Quindi io dovrei
salvare la partita che ho appena salvato
Tra l'altro mi dovrei fare un girello
per le caverne perché questo che ci
serve ragazzi se no non andrò mai avanti
Ok bene e anche l'altro bunker è stato
scoperto Let's go Allora ragazzi Noi
eravamo entrati in quelle caverne a
destra che ci sono là eh Io direi di
andare nelle altre quelle che sono
dritte perché effettivamente quelle non
le ho viste Ce ne sono un sacco di
caverne in realtà Ragazzi ho appena
scoperto che si può zoomare la mappa
Ma che cazzo dite Ma ragazzi ma è pieno
di bunker Ma minchia ma l'ho appena ma
non Ma ragazzi si può zoommare la mappa
e dire ma perché perché in questo gioco
non ti spiegano niente
Minchia ma ci sono un miliardo di bunker
tanto non è qua vicino Oh scusa non
avevo visto che stavo entrando nel Scusa
Vabbè vi fotto un po' di roba e poi me
ne vado Grazie
posso aprire qua dai che mi serve roba
poi me ne vado me ne vado adesso giuro
prendo solo un po' di roba
[Musica]
usa la radio
Salve o la maschera Vediamo se con la
maschera mi fa qualcosa Aspetta un
attimo
Eh hai visto eh Adesso ti faccio paura
io eh come cazzo questa questa stampante
3D è zio
Ma guarda che mi viene a vedere chi sono
Oh porco due di tua madre morta bastardo
Vabbè mi sono cagato addosso Ragazzi
andiamo via Però è stato interessante
visto che questa esigenza Molto
interessante grazie A cosa serve sta
minchia di maschera Allora Scusate raga
Buongiorno ragazzi Buongiorno questo
quanto cazzo è che cosa stra cazzo state
facendo qua Non volevo rompere le palle
arrivederci e continuate così che stai
facendo un ottimo lavoro siamo quasi
arrivati al bunker Raga ci siamo raga
Eccoci qua c'è altri Candy dove ci sono
i Caddy c'è un bunker Cos'è sta roba qua
se per vedere per rilevare i fantasmi
Cos'è sta roba qua
devo scavare vedi che mi serve
la pala Raga dove la trovo la pala la
pala e tutto quello che ci serve per
andare avanti nel gioco scaderei a mano
ma non posso non è che la posso craftare
la pala secondo me va trovata ma non ne
ho idea di dove posso trovare una pala
cioè devo provare una caverna randomica
vedere che succede una volta trovata la
pala finiamo il gioco praticamente non
lo so proviamo a entrare nelle caverne
ragazzi è l'unica perché ho fatto giri
chilometrici Eccoci qua le caverne sono
dovrebbe essere questa l'entrata Allora
l'entrata l'ho trovata ma Scusate un
attimo Salve e ho visti da lontano
volevo capire se potete darmi una mano
No vabbè grazie Tu tipo qualcosa una
palla ce l'avete Mi serve un casco
Oh merda Oh merda Va via via via via via
via via via le caverne presto Ah ce li
avrò mai ci arrivo veloce Brava brava
Zazza mi ero dimenticato di fare l'auto
ragazzi Quindi la sto facendo adesso con
la webcam perché magari quando registro
se faccio l'altro è meglio Comunque ho
appena finito di montare video che avete
visto stanno uscendo video di the forest
un giorno sì un giorno no Quindi
tranquilli che continua molto presto
continuate a guardare gli episodi perché
tra poco ci sarà risvolto incredibile di
trama di the forest quindi ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale e ci vediamo
dopodomani con un altro episodio di the
forest bella ragazzi